Gavin Newsom however the governor of
California who wants to run for
president
he claims California is the freedom
State he's in a big spat right now with
Governor Ron DeSantis over in Florida
Governor DeSantis says that he is a
model of freedom in America Newsome says
that's BS that's not true so DeSantis
was just in California for a speech at
the Reagan Library
Ron DeSantis ran an ad
and the ad said welcome to the real
Freedom state
feel free to read a book
get health care
say gay
what does that mean when he says feel
free to read a book he's talking about
the the bands that Florida has
instituted in schools on gay pornography
so Rhonda Santos he has banned books
that's true that's a real criticism that
you can make of him I think I don't
think it's a criticism I think that's
something he deserves praise for
these banned books specifically gay porn
in schools
and Gavin Newsom rather is saying well
here in California you can read gay porn
wherever you want you again boy you can
read it at the library you can read it
in the elementary schools you can get
all sorts of gay porn you want then he
says the next example of freedom is
you can get health care
the freedom to what maybe you get some
service from the state but what happens
when the state provides Health Care in
the places where this is practiced the
quality of the healthcare plummets ask
anybody from the United Kingdom ask
anybody from Canada some people you
can't ask in Canada because they've died
while they're waiting to get health care
and what's the solution to that by the
way when when the supply of Health Care
is is much smaller than the demand for
health care in Canada one people die
waiting to get surgeries but two the
state encourages people to kill
themselves that's why you're seeing a
big push among Canadian politicians for
maid medic medical assistance and dying
just doctor assisted suicide we say oh
you're poor you're a drain on society
you should probably kill yourself and
it's and it's exploding in Canada it's
not one or two people it's a huge huge
problem so that's the the the freedom to
have the state tell you to kill yourself
and then the third one say gay and of
course no State bans anybody from saying
the word gay you can even sing the word
and say I'm pretty I was so pretty
pretty and witty and gay you can sing it
anywhere you want any of these 50 states
but when they say say gay they mean have
five-year-olds taught about weird gay
stuff and transgender and all the rest
of it California oh we'll trans your
kids in preschool you you've got the
freedom you've got the freedom to tell
your kid to chop his genitals off when
he's five years old that's Freedom right
okay that's a vision of freedom
that is a vision of freedom from the
left and Gavin Newsom is owning it Ron
DeSantis has a different vision of
Freedom he was just asked on television
by Sean Hannity about Gavin newsom's
claim to be the freedom State and
specifically they they took this in the
direction of the fight over illegal
immigration here's what DeSantis had to
say
in Florida we're not a sanctuary State
when I became Governor we were able to
ban Sanctuary cities the rule of law is
important and so of course we're not
going to recognize uh Lawless
identifications that are done by
California and California they've
abandoned the rule of law they are a
sanctuary State they don't follow
Federal immigration laws and of course
the Soros prosecutors they pick and
choose which laws to enforce there'll be
people in Los Angeles who will get
mugged Sean on the street and the
prosecutor won't bring charges against
these guys and they end up going out and
they victimize other people so I think
Public Safety is incredibly important
and when you abandon the rule of law you
end up getting a lot of the results that
they've had in California and people
respond by fleeing the jurisdiction
I love this answer from DeSantis and I
know he's speaking specifically here
about immigration and then leading that
into Street crime a little bit but but
the answer I think suffices for his
whole view of freedom
which is that freedom comes
within the bounds of law
Gavin newsom's argument is that true
Freedom comes from licentiousness
and that's the great debate of our age
there are some people who say the great
political debate of our age is between
capitalism and socialism
or the great political debate of our age
is between
freedom and slavery I don't know
no the great political debate of our age
is between two
polar opposite conceptions of freedom is
freedom the ability to do whatever you
want according to your individual
appetites and desires that's what the
left says or is freedom the ability to
repress some of your desires
in favor of an exalted freedom
the freedom
to walk down the street without fear of
being mugged because people are
following the law the freedom to control
your sexual passions or your desire for
food or booze or anything else the
freedom to not have to be in a culture
infested with drugs the freedom to to
say no to those drugs that involves laws
against drugs
not the freedom to just go into any
country willy-nilly whatever you want
because borders don't exist no the
freedom to rely on your borders to know
that you have a distinct political
Community with a citizenry that can
govern itself that higher political kind
of Freedom that's the debate these two
guys are right now
running the the shadow campaign for
president the two leading candidates for
president right now are Joe Biden on the
Democrat side and Donald Trump on the
Republican side
both of those candidates are relatively
aged obviously Biden seems much older
than Trump but they're both they're both
there
if Biden does not run Gavin Newsom is
currently the leading candidate to
replace him Kamala is going nowhere
Buddha judge is a joke so Newsome is is
the top Runner
and DeSantis as you can see according to
all of the polls is the number two guy
in the GOP field
so the race will still probably be Trump
versus Biden
at least that's what the polls show
right now but if it's not
you could have a very honest debate
between two young
candidates
both governors of their own States
you can look at the record in those
States you can look at which way the
moving bands are going you can look at
where people are flourishing you can
look at where the economy is doing well
where social life is doing well where
families are growing
which conception of Freedom do you want
to live under
do you want to just do whatever you want
George Bernard Shaw I think it was Shaw
described hell is the place where you
have nothing to do but amuse yourself
well that's California
read whatever gay porn you want do
whatever drugs you want defecate on
whatever sidewalk you want to or
is is freedom
uh the ability to live a flourishing
life the right to do what you ought to
do in the words of Lord Acton
it's a good it's an honest debate to
have I don't even blame Newsome he's
honest about his view his view just
happens to be hideous California
is proposing a plan for reparations for
slavery
you've heard these ideas floated in the
far left fringes in recent decades
well now
it looks like it's pretty close to being
implemented the irony is that it might
first be implemented in a state
that never had slavery
not only a state that never had slavery
but a state for which the decision not
to have slavery was one of the
motivating factors for the Civil War
but California is now looking into it
the amount of money
that this state committee is considering
giving to each eligible recipient
is 50 more than the amount that was
floated as the highest possibility last
year
if
you are fortunate enough to be a black
person in the state of California
you might soon find yourself the
recipient
of 360
000 dollars
all because one of your ancestors maybe
was a slave
somewhere other than California all paid
for by the California taxpayers today
people who came here or whose ancestors
very likely came here long after slavery
existed people whose ancestors did not
practice slavery even if they were some
of the original Californians they will
pay you 360 thousand dollars and by the
way the number could be a lot higher
depending on what city you are in if you
live anywhere in the state of California
and you're a black guy who can claim any
even tenuous connection to slavery you
could be the recipient of up to three
hundred sixty thousand dollars if you
live in San Francisco you might be
eligible for five million dollars
so good incentive to move over to San
Francisco California by the way has a
state budget deficit of about 25 billion
dollars
this year
many cities also short
of money in California
I'm really glad that these that these
studies and committees are out there now
because it proves something that many of
us have known from the very beginning of
this reparations nonsense but I think is
quite clear now
there is no limiting principle on
reparations
if
if the proposal were
give every black person in America even
the Rachel dollazals even the people who
aren't really black but they identify as
black anybody anybody just give anybody
who was really interracial grievance
give them
360 thousand dollars
give them five million dollars and then
that's it
and then that's it the deal is you get
five million dollars but then you have
to shut up about racial grievance you
can't bring it up again if that were the
deal
everybody in the country would go for it
I I certainly would
oh if that were I don't care if it's a
trillion dollars that it costs if the
deal were you get five million dollars
and then you need to shut your trap
about racial grievance every single day
of the week every PR you stub your toe
it's because of white supremacy or
whatever okay great five million have
have six million dollars okay fine but
we all know that's not the case
we all know that's not the case because
one money does not buy happiness money
does not solve all problems money does
not even solve many problems money is a
fine thing to have in its proper place I
certainly enjoy having money rather than
not having money when it can be put to
good use but this is not merely a
physical world
and the the important things in life are
much deeper than that
uh two
if a state
they didn't even have slavery is now the
epicenter of this debate you know
there's no limiting principle
there is no limiting principle at all
and so I would recommend to California
that the reparations amount should be
zero dollars
and zero cents but I'm no longer a
California resident even though I happen
to be in California right now on the
road
for hurry fun and special little project
I I would not recommend that and I would
recommend unless you were black and you
can really claim the 5 million in which
case hey good for you enjoy but if
you're if you're uh gonna plan on a
long-term strategy of raising a family
somewhere I would not recommend
California things are not looking very
great there
[Music]
foreign